it looks like your voyage to the
Andromeda galaxy has been put on hold
Mass Effect Andromeda the long-awaited
fourth game in Bioware's acclaimed
sci-fi RPG series has been delayed too
early 2017 and a newly published blog
post eyewear said the release date delay
was necessary to make sure we deliver
everything the game can be and should be
the studio also revealed that Mass
Effect Andromeda would be showcased at
the EA play conference on sunday june
twelfth days ahead of e3 when Andromeda
was teased at e3 last year it was
expected to launch holiday 2016 but back
in March an EA executive suggested that
it would ship in fiscal q4 which runs
from January to March 2017 writing in
the blog post Bioware general manager
Ehren Flynn suggested the delay was
decided to ensure the Mass Effect
projects meet internal quality standards
as we've been playing the game at the
studio recently it's showing us that
we're taking the game in the right
direction he says we haven't seen much
from Andromeda so far but it sounds like
it'll take place after the events of the
first trilogy whether you're a paragon
or a renegade you'll want to keep your
space ships docked at gamespot for all
the latest news on mass effect